how you doing Terry I'm doing better
that for talking to you so how is this
team physically entering this series
we're here and Marcus smart is out for a
while what do you took what what do you
do a lot of people know about the market
smart situation so you know obviously a
lot of guys ready to step up and stuff
like that so you know that's just will
react we have practice today and you
know just trying to have fresh bodies
integrate for Sunday how challenging is
this year been for you to figure out
your role the team's role what what just
everybody's role it seems like it's it's
been a year-long process Terry yeah no
it's definitely been a year-long process
but so in a lot of different ways I
would say personally it's been tough I
feel because the opportunities to myself
is just kind of like Wednesday took it
away but it was just a lot different
than last year I feel like I went
presented with the same opportunity
which is fine you know we got a lot of a
lot of guys so you know just trying to
find that balance of knowing when I
would be out here put it for that amount
of time and trying to be efficient and
things like that but he does that as bit
tough I think all of us so what what
would you describe your role as being
heading into this now crucial win or go
home portion of your schedule Terry I
feel like I'm more needed now especially
with the Marcus smart situation and I
have been obviously I'm a big plans for
more minutes and you know I thought my
energy off the bench is on being the
most record for me and making when in
place Championship place to help us get
over out okay and and what is your role
been in this locker room do you think
Terry like I'm just one of the guys that
just try to help make make it easier for
us you know we got like I said we have a
lot of talent but you know communication
goes a long way you know with all that
time we have on this team still needs a
lot of guys to communicate so I feel
like I'm one of the guys that uh you
know make it easier for my teammates and
stuff like that and I'm still trying to
learn and get better at that
would you say is the leader of the team
if somebody came up to you who was a
leader of the Boston Celtics your answer
Terry Rozier would be what uh I would
say our workers just because of his time
being in the league and him you know
just having that connection with a lot
of different guys I feel like he's he's
our backbone another guy who says it's
Capri just because you know he already
been in this position plenty of times
he has like I said he been down this
road this is not his first rodeo and you
know he can lead all of us cuz he know
what it takes
he played on him them teams I made it to
the championship so that's always a big
help guys I had that experience yeah one
of the big one of the big things this
year Terry are certainly a national
conversation was when Kyrie came out and
said he apologized to LeBron for not
understanding the tough love that LeBron
was administering and how it would be it
was all in the assumption or in all in
the spirit of of winning this Kyrie dole
out tough love to to you great
relationship obviously he's going to
step in and say what he feels
regarding helping me and I think he's
always been great at that we never had
bad blood out into it and he has always
been a great help to me and got it I
look up to basketball level so you know
person yeah I would say it's it um this
is tough love our you wanna put about
would say he don't bite help okay and
last one for you on this subject do you
believe the earth is round or flat Terry
no that's crazy cuz back in my day I
stayed with black tube but I don't want
to get insects don't want nobody calling
me back in your day what do you mean
back when you were a kid bacterial ooh
okay so you know I'm glad nobody add
haven't been pointing that out and they
left me alone about it okay
I don't mean I don't mean to bring up
tougher times then but so you you would
answer round now to that question round
or flat you would answer I don't know
which one it is
okay Terry Terry Rozier Boston Celtics
guard right here on the program what is
it like being in a huddle with your
coach drawing up a play meeting point uh
meeting a basket to win walk me through
it that process is with Brad Stevenson
you know even when I wasn't first plan
like my first year too I used to always
join the hub's just to see what coach
you draw up and sometimes there's some
type of place like we're by the garage
of the bike it's crazy but it always
work out I feel you know you just had
some some real she's a real genius in
his ways of trying to get guys open
shots and knowing what the deep inside
were they gonna react to and stuff like
that so as always I feel like crazy and
when we got to go out there and come out
of huddle and play defense and and
remember to play to a truck
sometimes everybody's always could get
to play that he talked though because
it's super crazy but you know it works
and like I say he has a feel for this
game watching a lot of film in his plays
is crazy
well what did it mean to you to see Drew
Bledsoe rocking a scary Terry shirt and
having having your back last playoff
season
Terry you know about me accidentally
saying his name
bring him back to Boston you know them
wearing my scared Terry shirt and they
send me wine and stuff like that you
know we kind of talked a couple times
this year so I just been been dope to
grow that relationship with him but you
know a guy like that things he did for
this city so you know I think it it all
worked out was unique I know it's great
it's just I know I know God Chris
Brockman my Celtics buddy here on the
set you love that whole vision it was
amazing and so awesome yeah and I
appreciate that I'm glad it worked out
like that do you have a scary Terry
t-shirt I do have a scary Terry t-shirt
at home fantastic
so is scary Terry coming out against
Indiana Terry was scary Terry gonna be
here but I don't know if the search
gonna be okay
that way good to know all right so tell
me about your your twelve blessings and
your foundation here access sports
America what what do you what can you
tell me about this Terry oh oh yeah
today we was um today it was like a
natural fit so you know my sister has
cerebral palsy and you know work with
kids today that was obviously have
disabilities and you know at this school
the school that with the school is
called an agent English yeah English
English school is a course I'm doing a
basketball today they did a lot of
different types of sports in up there
but I never did a basketball been up
there so now I want to do that my sister
would probably shouldn't ball with it
and you know me and my sister is very
close so you know with the whole
foundation to a business thing I always
try to connect with you know people that
that have disabilities we did that today
we get up there dissing basketball
drills connecting with the kids and that
all worked out you know by my trainer
Anthony wills he helped design the whole
program today so he knows it was a nice
little event was up there at the English
school today very English high school in
Jamaica Plain today to officially launch
the new curriculum and how can people
get involved if they want to know about
this foundation and obviously what
you're doing with twelve blessings to
see if they can replicate it in their
own hometown right so pledget
Cantonese don't be on my bio on
Instagram and Twitter okay so I'm not
sure everybody can connect and great to
make it easier for them yeah basically
the goal is to help everyone feel like
an athlete and create those feelings in
the company
okay have pride and confidence so that's
my hope fantastic hey Terry good luck in
the playoffs let's chat throughout the
playoffs if you're up for it appreciate
you calling in of course and I love what
you're doing obviously with your with
twelve blessings there that's that's
great work that you're doing there in
the community thanks for the call I
appreciate that you bet that terry
rozier at t underscore rose
three four more of the Rich Eisen
showtune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app